peu
et maintenant joueront alors je vous
rappelle que le kaléidoscope et à 500
francs et vous faites un jeu complet oui
mais vous savez comment comment voulez
vous une note
notre mieux mais bon ce n'est pas non
mais ce mardi sous la dent contre
acheter mais parce que là c'est que vous
êtes en plein là je sais pas si vous
avez aimé savoir vous le voyez les nus à
huîtres est tout à fait bien
sinon on va courir comme ça et là
maintenant il faut que vous êtes touché
la côte mais bien je fais que ça vient
non bien que j'ai fait est là mais bien
mais je touche ouais bon des contrats
mais comprend pas le français touchent
la touche nous avons bien je vous
remercie beaucoup mais la prochaine fois
j'espère que je comprendrais que la fête
est finie ou à 3 minutes que je fais que
tout ça j'avais pas compris que vous
ayez retouches
[Musique]